a wall of water dust and rock
roars down the dalaganga river in
northern india
the bridges and dams in its path damaged
or destroyed
a portion of the nanda devi glacier is
said to have broken off
sending the torrent surging down the
mountain and through narrow valleys
below
people living on the river and several
nearby tributaries
were warned to move to safety
immediately
people are being evacuated from the
areas near aleknanda as a precautionary
measure flow of bhagirathi river has
been stopped
to prevent the flow of water from
alagnanda srinanga dam and rishikesh dam
have been emptied rescue teams in the
military quickly arrived at the area
where dozens of people were working on
major hydropower projects
like the tapivan vishnugad plant which
was under construction
others scrambled to reach at least one
blocked tunnel
where people were trapped inside
narendra modi in these difficult times
the modi government is standing shoulder
to shoulder with the people of
uttarakhand
the disaster management teams along with
other security forces are already there
the indian air force is also on alert it
is our priority to minimize the loss of
life and property to the people of
uttarakhand and restore normalcy here
uttarakhand in the himalayas is prone to
flash floods and landslides
in june 2013 record rainfall caused
devastating floods
that claimed close to 6 000 lives
that disaster was dubbed the himalayan
tsunami because of the torrents of water
which buried homes
and swept away buildings roads and
bridges
a former water resources minister
umabati
and other environmental experts have
criticized the construction of power
projects in the area
pointing to its fragile ecosystem and
the damage
caused by the 2013 floods it seems like
the power plant which was right in the
way of this
uh this disaster today was actually a
less than 15 megawatt hydropower plant
the question is should we be
compromising the ecological integrity of
himalayas
for such small projects more questions
will no doubt be raised after this
latest disaster
for now though the rescue operation
continues
alexi o'brien al jazeera